[Music]
Thomas Jefferson is revered as America's
third president and its first Secretary
of State
he's also the main author of the
Declaration of Independence and one of
four presidents on Mount Rushmore what's
less known is his role as an architect
to help shape the look of early America
an exhibition at the Chrysler Museum of
Art in Norfolk Virginia is exploring
that old and little-known legacy in a
very modern way
brook silva-braga is back from a visit
there Brooke good morning good morning
guys Thomas Jefferson was many things a
politician and a diplomat a naturalist
and a scientist but it's his work as an
architect that's getting special
attention at the moment because it
illustrates both the brilliance of his
vision and what too many is an
unforgivable blind spot just the title
of the show will surprise some of us
Thomas Jefferson architects yes I'm not
sure I even knew that or I forgot it he
was an architect not a professional but
one of the most advanced architectural
thinkers of his time Eric Neal
the curator and museum director says
evidence of Jefferson's influence this
is the Virginia Capitol yes is how
familiar his designs now look so this
looks almost like a cliche of a
government building now it wasn't then
Jefferson was saying we want to do like
what the ancient Romans and what the
ancient Greeks did because they had the
highest form of government and the
legislators acted with wisdom and the
architecture should convey that
Jefferson's plantation home Monticello
carried those principles
this was the drawing that Jefferson
submitted so did his anonymous
submission to a design competition for
the White House this dome was to have
glass windows
it was the most innovative it was the
most advanced well even today this looks
almost futuristic yes I'm not sure could
actually have been built that may be why
it looks like something I haven't seen
these models first appeared at an
Italian retrospective on Jefferson's
architecture Neel saw that show and
wanted to bring it home to Virginia but
realized that was a complicated idea
would it be going too far to say that
you thought that exhibition wouldn't be
well received here it wouldn't be enough
and if I had presented that exhibition I
would have rightly been criticized
Jefferson's designs after all were made
into buildings by slaves yes as a
politician he helped end the Atlantic
slave trade but at Monticello and
elsewhere Jefferson owned more than six
hundred human beings including his own
mistress Sally Hemings do we know who
made this in some cases we do in some
cases we don't so Neil enlisted a
diverse group of advisors to make a new
kind of exhibit it's a very fine work of
art highlighting the otherwise anonymous
people who built things like this door
they've been able to analyze the grain
and the grooves and the details of the
door and connect that to a set of tools
that are known to have been John Hemings
John Hemings was Sally Hemings brother
we don't know who the fingerprints in
this brick belonged to but here it is
under glass next to a handful of
handmade nails and a tribute to Isaac
Granger one of the men who made
Jefferson's nails he's wearing his
workman's apron and his shirt he's
showing you his hands which are signs of
his creativity love it or hate it the
exhibit is a profoundly different way to
present Jefferson I could see people
saying this is an American Hero why are
you trying to bring him down I could see
people saying this is a slaveholder why
are you still building him up I've
gotten a couple letters how could you do
this to Thomas Jefferson why would you
tarnish the image of this great man and
I've had other people say really we want
to give praise to this man who really
had a concubine who had a slave mistress
the reassessment of Jefferson the
architect will continue this spring at
the University of Virginia a campus he
designed
when UVA dedicates this memorial to
enslaved laborers the enslaved worked
below in kitchens that were poorly lit
poorly ventilated Columbia University
professor Mabel Wilson worked on both
the UVA Memorial and the Chrysler
exhibit she studies architecture and
race and says one of Jefferson's
hallmarks was finding ways to hide the
places where slaves lived and worked I
think this is what makes him an
architect that he understands
that the buildings make relationships
between people so he is very shrewd at
using architecture to make invisible
something that he completely understood
was morally reprehensible and against
the values of freedom and equality this
is all part of a larger reckoning in
Virginia for so long we've only told one
side of the story
Janice Underwood is Virginia's
first-ever director of diversity equity
and inclusion hired by governor Ralph
Northam after a racist photo was found
on North homes yearbook page
Virginia's second governor was Thomas
Jefferson who designed the Capitol
building where Underwood now works
he said that all men are created equal
and while I know that to be true he
would not have included me in that he
would not have included Sally Hemings in
that or any of his children with Sally
Hemings Underwood says she isn't sure if
the statue of Jefferson just behind the
Capitol should even stay up so I don't
know we're reckoning with those
questions now in its way the Chrysler
museum is attempting answers to the
questions of Jefferson by teaching new
names and attaching new meaning to old
ones do you want them to come away with
the idea that Thomas Jefferson was a
great American or maybe just an
important American I would say he's a
great American I would say the idea that
we have a president who has ideals that
we still aspire to it's really something
I want people to take away with them to
recognize he fell short of his
aspirations I hope they come away with
that as well
a handful of other museums across the
country are making a similar shift in
some cases actually changing the labels
next to paintings to explain that the
person in the portrait was involved in
the slave trade an important point to
make a great American he may have been
but a flawed one if you hold regard to
the writings of the man himself all men
are created equal it's it's the contrast
or even the hypocrisy at the center of
this exhibition and a lot of the
re-examination of Jefferson is so
important to understand
the past the full story or even news is
a great story
you